some of you may have noticed that today
I am wearing a t-shirt a very stable
genius t-shirt with original Trump
cartoon artwork some of you may have
noticed that Pat is wearing also a
t-shirt and maybe you can back up a hair
Pat which have a cup just ill tell you
but there there we go where you can see
Donald Trump stoop I'm sorry Donald
Trump's hair I mean that was a genuine
Freudian slip
which says this thing called nuclear
weapons like lots of things are done
with uranium including some bad things
and I also have here in front of me
another example t-shirt which is Trump
smiling with the quote if Ivanka weren't
my daughter which I think we can all
remember from actually many many times
during Donald Trump's life sadly these
are all new t-shirt designs submitted by
the audience including the great
Florian buns who has been working with
us for a long time and these are
available at david pakman.com slash gear
and people are loving these things
they're all available in a ton of
different colors we are going to
continue adding more designs but these
are conversation starters oh yeah to
call them anything they're very fun they
include the audience and of course we
still have the David Pakman show logo
apparel of course patriot male apparel
we have their coffee I mean there's this
a lot of that website coffee and coffe
fe both available at david pakman.com
slash gear yeah so check out the new
t-shirts we've got this thing called
nuclear-weapons t-shirt we've got the
very stable genius t-shirt we've got the
Ivanka weren't my daughter t-shirt plus
the established in 2005 hey treat male
logo t-shirt it's amazing what's going
on and now all of these are printed in a
different way than our old t-shirts so
the graphics really pop in a way that
they never used to I was practicing my
cat look up my catwalk all morning like
as a way to model this what is a catwalk
exactly like we walk down and oh like a
run show it off right yeah I go anyway
yeah but maybe we can do that on the
bonus show yeah I would not pay it I've
got a message from the management of the
building and because I guess you were
doing it out in front of literally in
the end of the building and at a time
when people were showing up to work and
it was it was causing a lot of a lot of
concern and I had to basically let's
just say I've had to negotiate not us
getting kicked out of our lease so
thanks Pat for that but yeah the
t-shirts attract a lot of attention as
Pat clearly demonstrated this morning
david pakman.com slash gear